[Music]
welcome back to harbor unboxed today
we're checking out amd's new radeon rx
6600 xt for the first time and this of
course is the msi gamingx version
now for those of you watching this video
as it went live so that'll be the 10th
the 6600 xt will be available tomorrow
on the 11th and
naturally you can expect to pay a hefty
premium over the 380 us msrp though amd
is telling me that they expect models to
be available at the msrp and that there
is pretty good supply of the 6600 xt
but of course we've heard the pricing
supply our promises before so yeah we'll
take that with a grain of salt for now
if we use the 6700 xt as a price guide
you can expect to pay around 600 us for
the 6600 xt and it appears as though
most of you were anticipating that price
based on the results of a poll we ran on
twitter last month the vast majority of
you expected pricing to land between six
and seven hundred dollars u.s which was
the lowest price bracket that we went
with above the msrp
anyway i'll save the detailed retail
pricing discussion for later when
examining the cost per frame data for
now let's focus on the claimed msrp
which sees the 6600 xt coming in at a 21
discount when compared to the 6700 xt
firstly it is important to note that
we're looking at new silicon with the
6600 xt as the navi 23 gpu is based on a
237 millimeter squared die packing 11.1
billion transistors so almost a billion
more than the old 5700 xt
enabled our 32 compute units providing
2048 stream processors 128 tius and 64
rops so that's a 20 reduction in cause
and tear use when compared to the 6700
xt
then when it comes to the memory
subsystem the 6600 xt suffers a fairly
substantial downgrade here dropping down
from the 192 bit wide bus to a 128 bit
wide memory bus so a 33 reduction there
and that means despite using the same 16
gigabits per second gddr6 memory the
bandwidth has also been reduced by 33
dropping from 384 gigabytes per second
to just 256 gigabytes per second
the memory capacity has also been
reduced by 33
dropping the vram from 12 gigabytes to 8
gigabytes it's also worth noting that
amd is targeting 1080p gaming with the
6600 xt and they suggest that 8
gigabytes of vram is suitable for this
resolution in 2021 but the downgrades
don't stop there the infinity cash
capacity has been slashed by a massive
reducing it from 96 megabytes down to 32
megabytes and with that the bandwidth
has also been reduced from up to
1459 gigabytes per second to 922
gigabytes per second and that's a 37
reduction
so the 6700 xt is 21 cheaper than the
6700 xt and on paper it appears as
though it's going to be at least 20
slower so in terms of cost per frame i
suspect at best it will match the 6700
xt
interestingly amd's been quite keen to
suggest that the 6600 xt competes with
the rtx 3060 rather than the 360 ti but
we're having none of that at 380 dollars
it's 15 percent more expensive than the
360 and just 5 cheaper than the 360 ti
so it's a bit cheeky there on amd's
behalf and really they are only offering
a 20 discount on a product that will no
doubt deliver lackluster rate racing
performance and while we very much like
fsr it's by no means good enough to
neutralize the dlss threat
another potential issue is the fact that
amd has gimped the pci express interface
and although it still uses pci express
4.0 that's probably an important point
to note they do want to stick pci
express 4.0 support on the box but the
bandwidth has been reduced to just times
eight now when installed in a pci
express 4.0 system that's really a
non-issue but performance related
problems could arise when installed in a
system that only supports pcie 3.0 which
admittedly is most systems
this is because when using pcie 4.0 the
6600 xt connects to the cpu using a 16
gigabytes per second link which is
sufficient for modern graphics cards as
that is what you get with pcie 3.0 times
16. however because we are limited to
pcie times 8 bandwidth when installed in
a pcie 3.0 system we get just 8
gigabytes per second and we have found
in the past that this can heavily limit
performance especially when fetching
data from system memory so i'll look at
pcie 3.0 versus 4.0 performance a little
later on
with all of that said let's go over a
few benchmarks using the msi gaming x
model but please note all benchmark
results are based on amd and nvidia gpus
running at the official specification so
no factory overclocking
in total i've tested 12 games at 1080p
and 1440p using our ryzen 9 5950x test
system which has been configured with 32
gigabytes of dual rank dual channel ddr4
3200 cl 14 memory okay let's get into
the results
starting with assassin's creed valhalla
the 6600xt gets off to a flyer beating
the rtx 3060 ti by a convincing 13
margin and the standard 360 by a massive
quite incredibly we're looking at rtx
3070 ti light performance here and
despite that it was still 15 slower than
the 6700 xt
that margin was extended at 1440p and
here the 6600xt trailed the 6700 xt by
19 margin rendering 60 fps on average
which is a pretty solid result something
worth noting here though is the fact
that the 6600 xt is five percent slower
than the 5700 xt that's pretty
disappointing given that it's meant to
be just five percent cheaper than the
now two year old radeon gpu
so while quite impressive when compared
to the geforce gpus in this amd
sponsored title the results are far less
impressive when compared to past and
current generation radeon gpus
moving on to shadow of the tomb raider
and right away i've got to say these
results look even less favorable for the
new mid-range radeon gpu here at 1080p
the 6600 xt was 19 slower than the 6700
xt and 17 slower than the rtx 3060 ti
while it was just two and a half percent
faster than the 3060 and four percent
faster than the old 5700 xt
the 1440p data though is even worse and
you can see the 6600 xt struggling due
to the more limited memory bandwidth
especially when compared to the 6700 xt
which it now trails by a 24 margin in
fact this new radeon gpu was only able
to match the cheaper rtx 3060 and again
we're looking at 5700 xt light
performance which i've got to say is
extremely disappointing given the price
point
watchdogs legion's another game where
the 6600 xt basically proves that it's
essentially a 5700 xt in terms of
performance and well price for that
matter with 72 fps on average it found
itself situated between the rtx 3060 and
3060 ti at 1080p but that meant it was
18 slower than the 6700 xt which isn't a
bad result but again not amazing given
the price
i guess you can see why amd were like
wink wink nudge nudge about the whole
6600 xt being a 1080p gaming gpu they
were probably hoping to persuade
reviewers just to ignore 1440p because
here we see that with 51 fps on average
it only matched the 5700 xt and that
meant it was now just 6 percent faster
than the rtx 3060 and 16 slower than the
3060 ti and 22 percent slower than the
6700 xt so a very weak result here at
1440p
those of you playing tom clancy's
rainbow six siege at 70p probably don't
require a 6600 xt but in the event that
you do here are the results the new
radeon gpu was good for around 300 fps
on average and that's the same level of
performance you'll receive from the old
5700 xt or 2070 super or i suppose the
new and cheaper rtx 3060 so again not a
particularly impressive showing
especially given that it was 25 slower
than the 6700 xt
and as we've seen a number of times now
the margins only increase at 1440p and
not the way a potential 6600 xt owner
would want them to here it was 29 slower
than the 6700 xt while losing out to the
old 5700 xt and the new and again
cheaper rtx 3060
moving on to horizon zero dawn we find
that at 1080p the new 6600 xt can once
again only match the 5700 xt while
offering a very minor improvement over
the rtx 3060 and i think it's fair to
say that's a disastrous result given the
suggested price worse still as expected
the 1440p data favors the cheaper rtx
3060 and now it's able to match the 6600
xt while the 360 ti was 23 faster so it
really does appear as though amd is
competing quite poorly with nvidia's
ampere lineup at this price point
the doom internal frame rates are
certainly very high here the 6600 xt had
no trouble pushing over 200 fps in our
test though that was only enough to just
match the rtx 3060 and old 5700 xt
meaning it was 21 slow on the rtx 3060
ti and 25 percent slower than the rtx
these results though at 1440p
uh very eye-opening and that's because
under these conditions do maternal
starts to max out the eight gigabyte
vram buffer and although it is possible
to turn down certain quality settings in
order to avoid this with no real
noticeable impact to image quality i
might add we deliberately opted not to
do that and instead use this as a more
forward-looking type benchmark
this is how i expect results to look in
future more memory demanding titles and
what's really key to note here is the
fact that both the 6600 xt and 360 ti
feature 8 gigabytes of vram yet the
geforce gpu is 55 faster so how can that
be
i believe the answer is down to memory
bandwidth more than anything else and
the rtx 360 ti just has a lot more of it
75 more in fact thanks to the much wider
256 bit wide memory bus
the 5700 xt also enjoys 75 more memory
bandwidth though it was only 19 faster
which is still a massive margin and the
only reason it's not larger is because
the shader performance is limited
so this is an interesting look at how
poorly the 6600xt performs relative to
competing parts in memory intensive
games
like most radeon gpus the 6600 xt does
perform well in death stranding
delivering 158 fps on average at 1080p
allowing it to match the 360ti which
frankly should be the minimum level of
performance offered by this product in
my opinion
jumping up to 1440p doesn't change the
picture all that much we're still
looking at 5700 xt light performance and
that meant it was also very similar to
the 360ti just three percent slower in
fact
next up we have cyberpunk 2077 and here
the 6600 xt was good for 75 fps on
average at 1080p making it comparable to
the 5700 xt rtx 2070 and rtx 360.
disappointingly though it was 14 slow in
the 30 60 ti and 20 slower than the 6700
xt
then as expected the margins continue to
head in the wrong direction for the 6600
xt when increasing the resolution at
1440p it's now 18 slower than the 360ti
and 24 slower than the 6700 xt
borderlands 3 is an amd sponsored title
and unsurprisingly it plays really well
with radeon gpus and here the 6600 xt
can be seen spitting at 92fps at 1080p
and they'll allow it to match the rtx
3060 ti which again is really where it
should sit overall if amd wishes to
justify their msrp
the 4040p margins are much the same
again the 6600 xt matched the rtx 360
gti as it delivered 5700 xt light
performance so not amazing and really
what you'd expect to see at this price
point
the hitman 2 results are quite typical
of what we've seen in the majority of
titles and that means the 6600 xt
performs closer to the rtx 3060 rather
than the 3060 ti despite being priced
closer to the ti model at 1080p it was
14 slower than the 3060 ti and just four
percent faster than the 3060 and as
we've seen time and time again the
margins extend slightly in nvidia's
favor at 1440p and now the 6600 xt is
seen trailing the 360 ti by an 18 margin
and now it's only able to match the 360.
the second last game we're going to look
at is resident evil 3 and here the 6600
xt was good for 166 fps on average 1080p
though that meant it was just seven
percent faster than the 3060 while
lagging behind the ti version by 14
margin
then at 1440p we're still looking at a
very healthy 102fps on average but that
did mean the new radeon gpu was 22
percent slower than the 360 ti so a very
disappointing result overall
and last up we have f1 2020 and yet
again we have another game where the
6600 xt is close to overkill at 1080p
rendering 163 fps on average using the
highest in-game quality settings and
that saw it trail the 360ti by a six
percent margin while besting the
standard 3060 by 12 margin though again
at the end of the day you could just
call it a 5700 xt
1440p sees more 50 700 xt light
performance and that meant that the 6600
xt was again a little over 10 percent
slower than the 360 ti so that's a look
at all dozen games tested now let's take
a look at the average performance
here's a breakdown of the 1080p data
from our dozen game sample and as you
can see on average the 6600 xt came out
nine percent slower than 360
which is pretty weak really and won't
position it well in terms of cost per
frame at least based on the mythical
msrp but we'll get to that soon
now even if we ignore the ampere
competition the 6600 xt is still
extremely underwhelming when compared to
amd's past efforts such as the 5700 xt
for basically the same price you're
getting well basically the same
performance years later and for me this
really does look like amd's turing
moment
then while amd would like to tell you
that the 6600 xt is a 1080p gaming
graphics card the fact is many of you
will want to use an almost 400 us
graphics card at 1440p and frankly
that's not asking a lot
and for those of you wanting to upgrade
to 1440p here the 6600xt slipped much
further behind the 3060 ti now trailing
up by a 16 margin and it wasn't a great
deal faster than the standard 3060 and
once again it's basically just a 5700 xt
also for those of you interested here's
what the 4k data looks like and perhaps
this can be used as a way to sort of
peer into the future as games become
more demanding the 360ti should still
for the most part be able to deliver a
60 fps experience while the 6600 xt
could fall off a cliff due to its
limited bandwidth previously we saw the
6600 xt was nine percent slow on the
3060 ti at 1080p then 16 slower at 1440p
and here at 4k it's 26 slower so again
that's not a positive look for amd's
near enough to 400 gpu
where the 6600 xt does shine is when
looking at power consumption here it
used no more power than the older 5600
xt when testing with doom at 1440p and
yet it managed to deliver 23 more
performance you're also looking at
around an increase of 100 watts for
total system usage with the 3060 ti so
at least in terms of efficiency the 6600
xt is very good
now let's move into some ray tracing
benchmarks and we'll start with
cyberpunk 2077 and please note due to
limited time with these cards i've only
compared the 6600 xt with the most
relevant part the 3060 ti
now standard rasterization performance
saw the 6600 xt trailer 360 ti by a 14
margin at 1080p
and with both using ray traced
reflections that margin blows out to a
44 percent deficit essentially without
the aid of dlss the 3060 ti can deliver
playable performance whereas the 6600 xt
simply can't and worse still there is no
way to boost the performance of the
radeon gpu outside of lowering other
quality settings
then with the aid of dlss the 360 ti can
be boosted back up to almost 90 fps on
average and while it's not an apples to
apples image quality comparison it's
still an option to achieve much greater
performance with ray tracing enabled or
alternatively you can use dlss without
ray tracing for an impressive 125 fps on
average
the doom maternal results are even more
brutal for the 6600 xt dropping from 228
fps on average to just 60 fps with ray
tracing on meanwhile the rtx 3060 ti
dropped from 288 fps 250 fps and while
that's an extreme 92 performance hit the
frame rate at 1080p was still far more
than what most gamers would require at
150 fps on average
and of course there's also the option to
enable dlss which reduced the
performance hit to just 29
but even without dlss enabled the 360 ti
was
150 faster than the 6600 xt with ray
tracing enabled so i'm not sure the word
brutal really conveys just how much of a
smashing that really is
next up we have a metro exodus enhanced
edition which can only be played with
the gpu supporting real-time hardware
accelerated ray tracing and therefore
ray tracing is enabled by default using
the lowest level which is labeled as
normal the 6600 xt was almost 50 slower
than the 360 ti and although it did
still deliver playable performance 137
fps is worlds better than 79 fps
in fact with the highest level of ray
tracing enabled at 1080p the 360 ti was
good for 97 fps on average while the
6600 xt struggled with just 45 fps
then with dlss it was possible to boost
performance up to 143 fps so another ray
tracing bloodbath there
even in resident evil village the 6600
xt simply couldn't hold a candle to the
ray tracing performance of the 3060 ti
offering around 40 percent less
performance using the low and mid tier
options
then we have the nvidia sponsored
watchdogs legion and really no surprises
here the 6600 xt gets dominated and is
really unable to deliver playable
performance dropping from an impressive
118 fps without ray tracing to just 36
fps using the medium quality
now as i mentioned earlier the 6600xt is
limited to pci express times 8 bandwidth
which is fine if you're running in the
pcie 4.0 mode but could be an issue for
those of you with a pci 3.0 system
the performance hit running assassin's
creed valahalla at 1080p is fairly
minimal though we are looking at a five
percent reduction performance and that
does bring the 6600 xt closer to the 360
ti in this title whereas previously did
have a reasonably large performance
advantage
we also found a five percent reduction
in performance when testing with death
stranding and this saw the 6600 xt go
from slightly leading the 3060 ti to
trailing it by a small margin
however in some games the reduced pcie
bandwidth makes no difference and we see
that here in cyberpunk 2077 as an
example
now as we saw previously do maternal is
very memory intensive when using the
ultra nightmare settings and while we
could simply turn the settings down for
better results i'd rather take a look at
how these graphics cards perform when
saturated as it should provide an
insight into future performance i have
to admit when i saw performance drop
from 228 fps to just 182 fps when using
pci express 3.0 my immediate reaction
was that something else had changed
maybe a quality setting or perhaps even
the resolution so of course i double
checked all of that and after several
back and forths it became clear that the
massive 20 drop performance was due to
the pcie mode
this means when using both the rtx 3060
and 6600 xt a pci 3.0 system while
playing doom under these conditions the
geforce gpu will be almost 30 percent
faster and perhaps just as shocking as
the fact that we found a way to make the
6600 xt slightly slower than the 5600 xt
as the older 5000 series part supports
time 16 bandwidth
of the 12 games tested we found on
average that the 6600 xt was just three
percent faster using pcie 4.0 or five
percent faster if we include the doom
eternal result so for the most part
those with pci 3.0 systems should
receive fairly similar performance to
what's shown using pcie 4.0 but in more
extreme cases the margin can be much
more significant and this is possibly
something we could see more of over the
next few years so i can't say i'm
particularly impressed with amd's
decision to potentially give the
performance of the 6600xt in this way
okay let's start by looking at the cost
per frame using the now controversial
msrp which due to extreme supply has
become a suggested price that's really
no longer remotely accurate even if
demand dried up overnight which isn't
even possible but let's say it did would
we see a return to msrp pricing
we probably would for future releases
but i doubt that would be the case for
current generation products pricing for
this generation was kind of set in stone
back when nvidia released ampere in
september of 2020 but since then a lot
has changed and aside from the demand
from gamers and miners shipping costs
have risen various tariffs have been
introduced and prices for not just
components but also raw materials has
increased and in most instances quite
significantly so since the release of
the geforce 3000 series prices of
various raw materials have risen by
between 30 to 50 percent think stuff
like copper aluminium and even plastics
for example
now if demand did dry out for graphics
cards that doesn't mean pricing of dram
along with the raw materials would
decrease as demand for those components
and materials would likely continue from
numerous other sources what that means
is getting 6600 xt's on shelves for the
380 us msrp could be extremely tight
perhaps not even possible without
selling them at a loss
so yes right now and likely for the
foreseeable the msrp is
bs
but if it weren't well the 6600 xt would
kind of suck offering worse value per
frame than both the rtx 3060 and 360 ti
while providing inferior ray tracing
performance no true dlss competitor and
a gimped pci express interface
so for a more realistic take on pricing
let's look to ebay.com so this is still
us pricing what we're looking at here is
the typical sale price for each product
on ebay over the past month though of
course the 6600 xt hasn't gone on sale
yet so i'm using the same markup as what
we see with the 6700 xt as that's
extremely likely where it'll end up now
if you're a bit confused by the 3060 ti
pricing as it is very close to the 3070
ti after all this is because demand for
3070 ti's from miners is lower as all 30
72 models are light hash rate and
therefore aren't as efficient for
cryptocurrency mining likewise the
demand from cryptocurrency miners for
the radio rx 6000 series is lower as
well as the infinity cache and rdna 2's
relatively small memory bus width
doesn't make them terribly efficient for
mining the 6600 xt then won't be a
sought after mining card and therefore
should end up being one of the most
affordable current generation gpus
estimated to be coming in at around 570
us at a cost of 4.45 per frame so in
that sense it should be fairly decent
value and i guess that's what amd's
banking on
now just before we wrap this up here's a
quick look at how the msi gaming x
version of the 6600 xt performed in our
gpu test system which is an enclosed
setup using the corset obsidian 500d
under load for 30 minutes the gpu
hotspot temperature peaked at 80 degrees
with a peak edge temperature of just 67
degrees the core is clocked at 2 640
megahertz on average which is about an 8
increase over the amd reference spec
this also raised the gpu power to 145
watts which is 15 watts above stock
despite the small overclock the gaming x
did run very cool and extremely quiet
with the fans operating at just 1100 rpm
so overall a fantastic result for what
really is a very well made graphics card
my only complaint though and here's a
bit of a frustrating one is the fact
that it doesn't feature a dual bios and
this really is a must-have item
especially for a premium graphics card
and it's disappointing to see that msi
hasn't included this on what is at base
price a 380 us product so there you have
it the radeon rx 6600 xt
basically just a 5700 xt in terms of
pricing and performance
with the addition of ray tracing and
directx 12 ultimate support
therefore in my opinion this is an
extremely underwhelming release but i
suppose let's be honest we weren't
expecting to be wowed given the current
climate that said i feel so amd's
managed to make the 6600 xt even worse
than anticipated by gimping stuff like
the pci express interface and then
heavily reducing the infinity cache
capacity making it weaker than expected
particularly for 1440p gaming if the
suggested retail price was still a thing
the 6600 xt would be a joke the laughing
stock of the rdna 2 lineup even based on
the 1080p data it's worse value than
either nvidia's offerings in terms of
rasterization performance
and of course it gets worse when you
increase the resolution
the only good thing i can say about the
6600 xt is that it sips power and due to
the lower demand you should be able to
buy it even so although we anticipate
that the 6600 xt will be the best value
option at places like ebay
it's still really hard to get excited
about it had amd made the msrp 300 us
then yeah the 6600 xt would be pretty
exciting honestly given the ray tracing
performance the lack of a true dlss
competitor especially for 1080p gaming
and the issues with the pcie interface
that is really the most amd should be
out of charge for this part but of
course with the industry being what it
is right now amd's basically saying
they'll happily make their margin on the
380 us msrp because you have no choice
but to pay whatever that translates into
in the real world
at the end of the day if these were
widely available for 570 us amd should
be able to sell a good many of them
though i'm not entirely sure about that
if we take local pc part seller pc case
gear for example we see that everything
high end is just really hard to buy even
at the heavily inflated prices
however parts like the rtx 3060 ti and
6700 xt or anything lower they're
relatively easy to purchase albeit again
at inflated prices and i believe this is
because gamers with deep pockets who
have their sites set on a high-end
graphics card are willing to spend
whatever they need to in order to secure
one and they're not willing to wait
whereas on the other hand mid-range to
low-end customers are quite the opposite
they're less willing to participate in
price gouging and just much more patient
and therefore likely to wait it out so
overpriced 6700 xt's and 30 60 graphics
cards just aren't selling nearly as
rapidly as expected and the demand for
the mediocre 6600 xt is almost certainly
going to be even lower i've been told
that as soon as parts like the 360ti are
available for under 1 000 australian
they just fly out the door basically
it's just not possible to keep them in
stock at prices like 850 dollars so this
does support my theory regarding
mid-range shoppers
okay let's pause for a minute i'm just
going to jump in here with some updated
information that we received last minute
for retailers and amd themselves
firstly amd seems very confident that
you'll be able to purchase a 6600 xt
at or very near the msrp and yeah i know
we've heard that one before however
checking with retailers it does sound
like that might actually be true
at least for the initial wave of stock
which i'm told is quite substantial at
least when compared to other releases
this year
now this sounds pretty crazy but i have
been told again by retailers that there
will be 6600 xt models available on the
11th for as little as 590 australian
which is the rrp recommended retail
price so what us aussies call the msrp
and then premium models will be priced
at 750 which is still exceptionally good
for reference the rtx 3060 starts at 800
aud but right now there's no stock
anywhere and if you want one in stock
you'll have to pay eleven hundred
dollars aud and quite shockingly the 30
60 ti lhr models are around fifty
dollars cheaper but that still sees them
priced north of one thousand dollars
australian
please note i am using australian prices
as i have good contacts with local
retailers but the point is it does sound
like the 6600 xt could be significantly
cheaper than both the rtx 3060 and 3060
ti and if that is the case it'll be
worth buying and really a highly
successful release basically everything
now hinges on pricing and availability
but if what i'm hearing is true then the
6600xt might actually end up being a
sought after gpu despite the various
shortcomings mentioned in this review
with graphics cards pricing and
availability really is everything
anyway we will keep an eye on 6600 xt
pricing and we do have a lot more 6600
xt content coming up and of course tim
will also update you with a gpu pricing
guide later this month so make sure you
subscribed for all of that and that is
going to do it for this day 1 review of
the 6600 xt
maybe things won't be as bad as i think
they will perhaps they will get these
cards available at the msrp in good
numbers they won't just sell that in a
matter of seconds i'm doubtful but amd
seems to think that you know it may be a
better situation than we've seen so far
but again uh we still got burnt on the
6800 series so i'm not going to take amd
at their word this time
we've said it how we how we see it and
if that ends up being too harsh and
these cards are much better value then
you know we can update that with content
down the track so we'll just wait and
see at this point but yeah so far a few
things about this card that i'm not
particularly impressed about anyway
that's enough about the 6600xt feel free
to like the video if you enjoyed it and
found it useful again subscribe for more
content because we have a lot more
coming and if you'd like to support our
work and also get some really cool perks
in return then consider subscribing to
the harvard unboxed patreon or
floatplane accounts you'll be uh become
a harbor box community member and get
access to really cool things like our
exclusive discord server where team
myself are active you can ask us
questions there and whatever else goes
on there we have a monthly live stream
that we do q and a's behind the scenes
content a lot of cool stuff so like i
said if you're interested check it out
links in the video description if not
perfectly fine and i would like to thank
you for watching this video i'm your
host steve and i'll see you again next
time
[Music]
you